now normally when we do these sequences
they're of course dedicated to all of
our viewers but there is a particular
small group of people who might well
benefit from what we're going to talk
about today because the public finances
are actually quite simple
it's worth just reminding yourself how
they work really it all just comes back
down to two numbers here the amount of
taxes that you're getting in and the
amount of spending you're doing and you
can see look taxes that bar is slightly
lower than this bar what does that mean
it means you need to borrow to make up
the difference so that's why we have
this deficit this is the year we're in
at the moment and of course no one likes
to borrow enormous amounts but it does
at least mean that you're not bankrupt
and each year
these bars which as i say that's
basically it when we're talking about
this stuff they tend to shift so look at
the couple of years time they're both
going up a bit higher but you've
probably noticed taxes rising faster
than spending this is one of the bug
bears for many people in this race at
the moment but the upshot of it is the
deficit is much smaller so down from 99
billion to 35 uh billion pounds uh and
for which you know that's really the
point you know it's about trying to
reduce the deficit over time and then
maybe having money uh left aside for tax
cuts in the future
but the big question is what are the
other candidates going to do about his
fiscal rules that basically mandate that
you're reducing the deficit we haven't
heard much detail about that instead
we've had rather a lot about what taxes
they're going to cut and not all that
much detail about how they're going to
pay for them so for instance a number of
them talking about cutting corporation
tax cancelling the corporation tax rise
it's supposed to go up to 25
but that would cost 17 billion pounds so
a lot of money and you can see that bar
going down slightly if you want to
reinstate the 15 rate then it goes down
even further by 31 billion pounds and
all the while actually this bar the
spending bar is getting a little bit
higher because we've got more money
being spent on that energy bill package
so you can see taxes down spending up
and that implies a bigger deficit
some would say and some indeed are
saying hang on actually some tax cuts do
pay for themselves well
maybe let's have a look george osborne
did cut corporation tax quite a lot and
it did actually raise more money uh than
it cost him but
there's a trick here let me show you why
so this shows you the amount that it
cost this is george osborne's tax cuts
going from 2010 through to 2018. and you
can see that's how much it cost okay so
it costs quite a lot of money but at the
same time as cutting that tax rate so
not bringing in as much from the main
rate he was getting rid of certain
incentives so that's falling tax revenue
he was getting rid of certain incentives
on capital allowances for instance
making it a bit less attractive to
invest and various other loss
restrictions and by the end of this
period actually that bar
of all the kind of
investment incentives that went was
bigger than that bar so it did raise
money but it came at a cost for
investment the other argument is if you
cut taxes it can boost productivity
growth boost gdp growth well again
in theory it's possible but just have a
look at what's happened in the past you
know this line shows you productivity
over the last few decades and these
yellow lines are all of those successive
forecasts yes it's going to rise it's
going to rise it's going to rise but
then it's basically flatlined and this
perhaps even more than public finances
is a really big deal this is what we
need to be talking about how can you get
productivity up because that boosts
everything else and at the same time how
do you deal with this the fact that real
household disposable income
is going to fall this year at the
fastest rate on record so there's lots
of stuff to talk about but it seems like
some of the candidates aren't quite
raising all these deeper issues quite
yet at least